you
Lo and welcome to these seventh video in
the tutorial series of machine learning
for use with stocks and Forex algo
trading where we left off we were
storing a whole bunch of patterns into
an array and basically into memory and
now what we want to do is actually us
begin the pattern recognition part of
this so basically what is our current
pattern that we have right now so we'll
come down here make another function and
we're going to call this define pattern
recognition mission empty parameters and
here we're going to make an empty array
for now Pat for wreck so this basically
stands for pattern for recognition so
what is that was the pattern in question
and for this we're going to make a bunch
of variables and it's going to be CP for
current pattern I'm just going to say 1
and so current pattern part 1 basically
and that is going to be again our
percent change and in here we're going
to use average line and where are we
currently in that pattern well minus 1
brings us to basically an array if you
call the negative first element in the
array it takes you to the last element
in the array subsequently if we did
negative 11 it would take you to you
know the last tenth or it's hard for me
to say that in words but if you get
negative 1 takes you the last element
the negative 11 takes you to 10 prior to
that so anyway that's our start point
right and then what would be the current
point that in question here will be
average line minus 10 okay
now what we're going to do for the other
ones very similarly to what we did
before is do 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 and what
we'll do is use not even the right spot
2 3 4 5
nann 10 and the other change that we
need to make is here instead of minus 10
this will be minus 9 a 7 6 4 3 2 & 1
so that will be the percent change from
point you know it kind of backwards
format right 1 2.2 2.3 2.4 2.5 6 7 and
so on starting from you know this point
so the percent change in the same format
as our pattern recognition now what we
actually need to do is store this so
pack for rec and what you could have
done is just say like a pen pad for rec
append this pad for recommend this pad
for recommending this but and then also
actually there would be an even better
way to do this with a for loop or a
while loop but again we're trying to
keep this pretty simple so that's why
I'm doing it this way and so what we're
going to do is append CP 1 and so now
we're appending all each part of this to
our pattern 3 4 5 6 8 9 10 and now 2 3 4
6 8 9 10 and just to make sure we did
everything right print Pat for Rick so
let's save that and run this pattern
recognition function pattern recognition
is not defined so do we define average
long as okay we the problem is we don't
have average line is the global variable
so what we need to do is move average
line out of pattern storage and into a
global variable so cut it there and put
this down there and paste average line
there that should be the only issue that
we're really going
have bring this back over LP okay so
this is our current pattern in question
and then what we would want to do is
compare it to previous patterns so in
the next video that's what we're going
to be doing we're going to take our
current pattern and compare it to the
patterns in our memory basically so stay
tuned for that as always thanks for
watching